this is a line that Kamala Harris has
used once or twice before
I can imagine what can be and be
unburdened by what has been you know
what can be unburdened by what has been
what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what we can
see what we believe can be unburdened by
what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been who we can
be
unburdened by who we have been what can
be unburdened by what has been where we
can be unburdened by where we have been
and unburdened by where we are right now
the thing I love about Kamala Harris is
she is her own sign language interpreter
so you don't need the little lady in the
corner of the screen